this is the awesome underpass when the
flash flood hit on Saturday emergency
crews estimated took just a few minutes
for the road tunnel to fill with water
trapping more than a dozen Vehicles
including a bus and its passengers
we all needed to take the situation
Gravely and mobilize all available
resources please make every effort in
the field to ensure that the rescue is
carried out quickly around 900 Personnel
are on the scene with Crews working to
pump water out of the tunnel
we are working while conducting drainage
and removing the mud the drainage has
progressed a lot over the weekend heavy
rains caused the banks of the nearby
Miho River to collapse flooding The
Underpass
research effort continues questions are
being asked about how such a tragedy
occurred with some residents criticizing
the preparedness of local authorities
some here say the underpass should have
been closed because weather warnings had
been issued chongju is one of several
areas in South Korea drenched by days of
torrential rain South Korea typically
experiences heavy rainfall at this time
of year authorities acknowledge the need
to have better contingency measures
given the premise that situations like
extreme heavy rain due to climate change
are now expected we need to consider our
disaster management plans for floods
weather warnings remain in place for
several areas in Central and Southern
provinces more heavy rain is forecast
for later this week Jessica Washington
Al Jazeera chongju South Korea
the temperatures are soaring on four
continents with